imagine the worst headache of your life
multiplied by a thousand you have it
every day for some people the only
medication that works are opioids my
name is Amy I'm from Cincinnati Ohio one
day I was walking to class and I simply
stepped off a curb came down on my knee
in my hands and then a couple weeks
later I had such intense screaming pain
down my arm the doctor diagnosed me with
cervical dystonia he started me on
regular Botox shots and then medications
usually muscle relaxers and then
sometimes pain medication my name is Ann
peek way and I'm from Birmingham Alabama
when I was a child I was originally
diagnosed with mild cerebral palsy as I
said you know wouldn't get any worse but
they didn't pick up on the fact that I
had dystonia and not CP at the time this
was the point that I first started
taking quote/unquote pain pills and
it was not something that I wanted to do
it all but it helped back when I was
down on lower dose well completely off
of the of yours yeah doing something
like you know just standing up like that
would be almost impossible by myself I
think what people don't understand is
pain medication is not something that
takes your pain away it helps take off a
little edge so that you're just not
completely screaming the problem is that
doctors are becoming increasingly
pressured to reduce prescribing for even
these chronic patients and they either
taper them off or they discontinue them
they're told to find other doctors I've
already had one incident where a
pharmacist would not fill my doctor's
prescription for my pain medication I
went into withdrawal I had a lot of
tremors and muscle aches and nausea and
she refused to fill the prescription the
doctor and this this is not uncommon at
all
much of doctors fear of prescribing
medications for people in chronic pain
can be traced to a guideline produced by
the CDC Centers for Disease Control in
2016
so many people I care about and y'all
have committed suicide and it's just
such a sad thing I mean basically back
then I was doing anything possible to
try to find a doctor and trying to make
the medication I had less as long as it
you know as long as it could but I had
pretty much decided that you know once
it runs out it runs out and if I don't
get any you know don't get any fluids
don't eat anything don't break anything
you know be over pretty quickly I mean I
don't want to die I mean I just don't
want to live like that's up
I am scared every single day that the
treatment that helps my condition will
become that every time I have an
appointment will be in a day that I'm
told I won't be helped anymore
you